Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast produced by the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. I'm joined by Dr. Philip Zimbardo, Professor Emeritus at Stanford University, perhaps most well known for his 1971 Stanford Prison Experiment. Over his 60-decade career, Dr. Zimbardo has done research, written books, and given TED Talks on a wide variety of topics, including evil, time, men's health, and shyness. Welcome, Dr. Zimbardo. Thank you. Great to be here with you. And so now you're in a new venture called the Heroic Imagination Project,
您好，欢迎收听由美国心理学会制作的播客《心理学谈话》。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。今天做客节目的嘉宾是斯坦福大学荣休教授菲利普·津巴多博士，他最广为人知的成就或许是1971年的斯坦福监狱实验。在长达60年的职业生涯中，津巴多博士在邪恶、时间、男性健康和害羞等广泛领域进行了研究、撰写了著作并发表了TED演讲。欢迎您，津巴多博士。谢谢。很高兴能来到这里。那么，您现在正在进行一项名为“英雄想象力项目”的新事业，
which inspires everyday heroism. Can you talk about that premise and explain how you train to be heroes? Yes. I would like everybody in the world to be a hero in training. And the idea was that after I did the Stanford Prison Study, which really in 1971, which is really a follow-up of the early work by Stanley Milgram. And many people don't know that little Stanley and I were in the same high school class at James Unrow High School in the Bronx in the 50s. But his research showed how easy it is for good people to violate their conscience
该项目旨在激发日常英雄主义。您能谈谈这个前提，并解释一下如何训练人们成为英雄吗？好的。我希望世界上每个人都能成为一名“在训英雄”。这个想法源于我在1971年进行的斯坦福监狱研究，这实际上是对斯坦利·米尔格拉姆早期研究的后续。很多人不知道，我和小斯坦利在50年代曾是布朗克斯詹姆斯·门罗高中的同班同学。但他的研究表明，好人违背良心是多么容易，
and harm another person at the request of an authority. I wanted to expand that to say, you know, more evil happens when people are playing roles, but nobody tells you to do anything wrong, but in that role, it becomes what you do. So if you're a prison guard, your job is to suppress prison riots. Your job is to dominate, control prisoners. And so there was a body of research now in social psychology. Milgram's study, my study, studied by my colleague Albert Bandura, to show how easy it is for good people to dehumanize others to steal to lie to cheat and harm other people and
并在权威的要求下伤害他人。我想将其扩展开来，你知道，当人们扮演角色时，更多的邪恶就会发生，虽然没有人直接让你做坏事，但在那个角色中，这成了你的行为方式。如果你是一名狱警，你的工作就是镇压监狱暴动。你的工作就是支配和控制囚犯。社会心理学中现在已经有了一系列研究，比如米尔格拉姆的研究、我的研究，以及我同事阿尔伯特·班杜拉的研究，都表明好人去非人化他人、偷窃、撒谎、欺骗和伤害他人是多么容易，
then in 2007 I think I gave a TED talk I think was 2007 and it was on the psychology of evil It was one of the most popular talks of how many millions of people have seen it but at the end of the talk I said I raised the concerns issue of we now know how easy it is for good people to be seduced into doing evil. But I said to the audience, do you think it's possible that we can inspire and even train ordinary people to become heroes? And it hit a responsive court. And that's, I had, I just wanted to have a dramatic ending to the talk. Many people in the audience came up, including Al Gore, Pierre Omidyar, the person started
然后在2007年，我想我发表了一次TED演讲，应该是2007年，主题是关于邪恶心理学。那是当时最受欢迎的演讲之一，有数百万观众观看，但在演讲结束时，我提出了一个担忧，即我们现在知道好人被诱导去做坏事是多么容易。但我问观众，你们认为我们是否有可能激励甚至训练普通人成为英雄？这引起了强烈的共鸣。当时我只是想让演讲有一个戏剧性的结尾。许多观众走上前来，包括阿尔·戈尔、皮埃尔·奥米迪亚（eBay的创始人），
eBay. hey, you have to follow this up. I said, what do you mean? You have to have a foundation. You have to have a team. So I did. So in 2010, I organized in San Francisco, the heroic imagination project.
他们说：“你必须跟进这件事。”我说：“什么意思？”“你必须成立一个基金会。你必须组建一个团队。”所以我照做了。因此，在2010年，我在旧金山组织了“英雄想象力项目”。
It's a nonprofit foundation in which what I've tried to do is to use basic knowledge in psychology, social psychology, cognitive psychology, as a training platform. So we want to inspire people, you know, meaning you should become a hero, you should do good,
这是一个非营利基金会，我试图做的是利用心理学、社会心理学、认知心理学的基本知识作为训练平台。所以我们想激励人们，你知道，意思是你应该成为英雄，你应该做善事，
but it's a different kind of hero. It's not military, it's not political. It's ordinary people, especially youth, doing daily deeds of goodness and kindness. And we teach you how to do it based on fundamental principles in psychology. And what are some of those success stories you've seen? I mean, some success stories you've had. Oh, so essentially, so we have these lessons that I've created
但这是一种不同类型的英雄。它不是军事上的，也不是政治上的。它是普通人，尤其是年轻人，在做日常的善行和善举。我们根据心理学的基本原则教你如何做到这一点。您见过哪些成功案例吗？我是说，您取得的一些成功案例。哦，基本上，我们有我创建的课程，
on how to transform passive bystanders into active heroes. Using all the research we know about from Dali and Latinae from the bystand effect. Using research from Carol Dweck, my colleague at Stanford, on how to transform people of a narrow, fixed, static mindset into a dynamic growth mindset. How to transform stereotype, prejudice, discrimination into understanding and acceptance of others who are different. So we have a number of these lessons. Each lesson is like three hours long. They're filled with provocative videos.
关于如何将消极的旁观者转变为积极的英雄。利用我们从达利和拉塔内关于“旁观者效应”的研究中了解到的所有知识。利用我斯坦福同事卡罗尔·德韦克关于如何将人们从狭隘、固定、静态的思维模式转变为动态成长型思维模式的研究。如何将刻板印象、偏见、歧视转化为对他人的理解和接纳。所以我们有许多这样的课程。每节课大约三个小时长。它们充满了启发性的视频。
And I and some of my team, we go around the world training teachers, training people in human relations, how to deliver these lessons effectively. And so the lessons are licensed for a relatively small fee to schools, school districts, prison setups or HR organizations within business. And our most, so we're now a dozen countries literally globally around the world. And it's our most successful program, surprisingly, is in Hungary. And in Hungary they found, have a foundation called Hero Square. And I'm on the board of directors.
我和我的一些团队成员走遍世界各地，培训教师，培训从事人际关系工作的人，教他们如何有效地传授这些课程。因此，这些课程以相对较低的费用授权给学校、学区、监狱机构或企业内部的人力资源部门。目前我们已经在全球十几个国家开展了项目。令人惊讶的是，我们最成功的项目是在匈牙利。在匈牙利，他们成立了一个名为“英雄广场”的基金会。我是董事会成员。
And what's astounding was I gave a talk there four years ago about this. At the end, several people came up and said, it's really interesting. Hungarians are the most pessimistic people in the world. So as soon as you say something new, they say, it won't work here. And I said, give me a chance. It's a challenge. So the next day, I actually did a workshop in a training, and now it's the most successful program in the whole world, meaning our program is in more than a thousand high schools,
令人震惊的是，四年前我在那里做过一次关于此的演讲。最后，几个人走过来说：“这真的很有趣。匈牙利人是世界上最悲观的人。所以一旦你提出什么新东西，他们就会说，这在这里行不通。”我说：“给我一个机会。这是一个挑战。”所以第二天，我实际上做了一个工作坊培训，现在它是全世界最成功的项目，意味着我们的项目已经在超过一千所高中，
in many, many businesses. What we do is often videotape and presented on... Hungarian TV, what would you do? So we reenact, you know, people lying on the ground and seeing who comes to help and who does it. And so that's our model program. But we're in Poland, we're in Bali, we're in Geelong, Australia, in Iran. We're in, I started a program in Tehran in Iran. Let's see, I'm about to go to Portugal, set up a program there. But it's really exciting for me to me to see this emerging. Curiously, since we're now an APA in San Francisco,
以及许多企业中开展。我们所做的事情经常被录像并在匈牙利电视节目《你会怎么做？》中播出。我们重现了人们躺在地上，看看谁会来帮忙，谁不会。这就是我们的模范项目。但我们也在波兰、巴厘岛、澳大利亚吉朗、伊朗。我在伊朗德黑兰启动了一个项目。让我看看，我正准备去葡萄牙，在那里建立一个项目。但看到这一切正在兴起，对我来说真的很令人兴奋。奇怪的是，既然我们现在在旧金山的美国心理学会，
our program is almost nonexistent in San Francisco, where I live. And partly because the head of school districts say we don't have time in our curriculum to add this. It seems interesting and important, but our students have all of their curriculum totally planned for them. And I say, you know what?
我们的项目在我居住的旧金山几乎不存在。部分原因是学区负责人说我们的课程表里没有时间增加这个。这看起来很有趣也很重要，但我们的学生所有的课程都已经为他们规划好了。我说：“你知道吗？”
that's really sad. If you can't work this in, it could even be obviously in an after-school program. So that's your next step is to, in your own backyard. Yeah, I mean, you have to make it work here as well. So I gave a talk this morning about the Hero Project. And people said, we want your program in Kenya. We want your program in Armenia for many different places.
“这真的很可悲。如果你不能把它安排进去，它甚至可以在课后项目中进行。”所以您的下一步是在您自己的大本营开展工作。是的，我的意思是，你必须让它在这里也能行得通。所以我今天早上做了一个关于英雄项目的演讲。人们说，我们想要你们在肯尼亚的项目。我们想要你们在亚美尼亚的项目，还有许多其他地方。
In Guatemala, you know, but nobody came up and said, we'd like to have your program here. So it's a paradox. I want to touch back on the Stanford Prison Experiment. Yeah. So I have a brief synopsis for those who might not be familiar. But it was in 1971 at Stanford University. There was nine men who were volunteers.
在危地马拉，你知道，但没有人走过来说，我们想在这里开展你们的项目。所以这是一个悖论。我想回到斯坦福监狱实验。好的。对于那些可能不熟悉的人，我有一个简短的概要。那是1971年在斯坦福大学。有九名男性志愿者。
So they were either the guards or the prisoners. And it was supposed to go for two weeks, but... Nine men guards and nine men prisoners. Okay, so 18. Yeah. And it was supposed to go for two weeks, but it ended, was cut short because essentially you were seeing that the guards are becoming psychologically abusive to the prisoners.
他们要么是狱警，要么是囚犯。实验原定进行两周，但……九名狱警和九名囚犯。好的，一共18人。是的。原定进行两周，但它提前结束了，因为基本上你看到狱警开始对囚犯进行心理虐待。
And that study has been used to explain human rights abuses from the Vietnam War to Holocaust and a variety of atrocities that have happened. But there has been criticism, and you've addressed that over the years. And most recently, there's been new criticism by the guards saying they were coached and one man said he faked a breakdown so he could study for his graduate exam. So what is your response to that?
那项研究被用来解释从越南战争到大屠杀以及发生的各种暴行中的人权侵犯。但一直存在批评，多年来您也对此做出了回应。最近，狱警们提出了新的批评，称他们受到了指导，其中一人说他假装崩溃以便复习研究生考试。那么您对此有何回应？
Yeah, so the state prison study has become maybe the most iconic, widely known, study in psychology, literally around the world. And the problem has been, from the very beginning, I said, this is really, it should not have been called Stav Prison Experiment, should have been called the Stambert Prison Exploration. It's really exploring the boundaries of human nature.
是的，斯坦福监狱研究已经成为心理学中最具标志性、最广为人知的研究，确实遍布世界各地。问题在于，从一开始我就说，这真的不应该被称为“斯坦福监狱实验”，应该被称为“斯坦福监狱探索”。它实际上是在探索人性的边界。
And so the terrible thing was, so in our study, we actually recruited 24 college students from all over America. They were not from Stanford. We did it at Stanford. And we gave them personality tests, clinical interviews. And we picked two dozen who at the beginning were the most psychologically healthy and normal. And then we randomly assigned half to be guards, half to be prisons. So we had nine prisoners, three in each of three cells, and nine guards, each of which worked eight hour shifts. And then we had backup prisoners and guards. And so again, at the beginning, there was no difference between a prison guard and again it's 1971 what does that mean you're in the
所以可怕的事情是，在我们的研究中，我们实际上从全美招募了24名大学生。他们不是斯坦福的学生。我们在斯坦福进行了实验。我们对他们进行了人格测试、临床访谈。我们挑选了最初心理最健康、最正常的两打人。然后我们随机分配一半人当狱警，一半人当囚犯。所以我们有九名囚犯，每三个囚犯关在一个牢房里，还有九名狱警，每人轮班八小时。然后我们还有候补的囚犯和狱警。所以再次强调，起初，狱警和囚犯之间没有区别，而且那是1971年，这意味着你正处于
middle of the Vietnam War students college students everywhere hate the police hate prison guards because when students protested against the war everywhere including a Stanford and I led some of those protests the administration often called the cops onto the campus and there were physical confrontations and And in some places like Ken State, Ohio, the National Guard actually killed students. So nobody wanted to be a guard. Now there's a movie, there's a Hollywood movie called the Stanford Prison Experiment, which just came out.
越南战争期间，各地的大学生都讨厌警察，讨厌狱警，因为当学生抗议战争时，包括在斯坦福，我领导了一些抗议活动，校方经常叫警察进入校园，发生了身体冲突。在肯特州立大学、俄亥俄州等地，国民警卫队甚至杀害了学生。所以没人想当狱警。现在有一部好莱坞电影叫《斯坦福监狱实验》，刚刚上映。
And at the beginning of the movie, it looks as it my staff is asking each of the people, do you want to be a prison guard, nobody wants to see a guard. Nobody likes guards. But what it meant was you had to be a guard. Everybody knew it was an experiment. You sign informed consent. And then the guards, we went with the guards, they picked out to Army Navy store the uniform.
在电影开头，看起来我的工作人员在问每个人，你想当狱警吗？没人想当狱警。没人喜欢狱警。但这意味着你必须当狱警。每个人都知道这是一个实验。你签署了知情同意书。然后狱警，我们和狱警一起去陆军海军商店挑选了制服。
So they're all now in military uniforms, which they hate the military, they hate cops. So they felt awkward. The prisoners were dehumanized. They were just in smocks with a number, and they became the number. And so on day one, nothing happened. In fact, what happened, one of the things
所以他们现在都穿着军装，而他们讨厌军队，讨厌警察。所以他们感到尴尬。囚犯们被非人化了。他们只穿着罩衫，上面有一个数字，他们就变成了那个数字。所以第一天，什么也没发生。事实上，发生的事情之一是
happened was you can hear so we made we have 12 14 hours of audio tapes of everything that happened and you can hear the guard saying come on guys let's take this seriously and i'm i'm looking i said oh my god this is not going to work i mean it's you know and um and then in fact uh the war so i played the role of superintendent and undergraduate david jaffy played the role of warden and i had two graduate students craig hayd and kirk banks who are my lieutenants But most of the time it was just guards and prisoners on the yard and we were looking in and making videos. And what happens is at one point, you know, there's, so there's three guards on this shift
你可以听到，所以我们制作了，我们有12到14小时的音频磁带记录了发生的一切，你可以听到狱警说：“来吧伙计们，让我们认真对待这件事。”我看着，我说：“天哪，这行不通。”我的意思是，你知道，而且……事实上，呃，战争……所以我扮演了主管的角色，本科生大卫·杰菲扮演了典狱长的角色，我有两名研究生克雷格·海德和柯克·班克斯作为我的副手。但大多数时候，院子里只有狱警和囚犯，我们在观察并制作视频。发生的情况是，在某个时刻，你知道，有三名狱警在轮班，
and you know, two of the guards are telling the prisoners do push-ups, count off your numbers, and one of the guards are sitting in the court of smoking a cigarette. So David Jaffe goes to him and says, come on, you're getting 15 bucks a day, you've got to do something. No, why don't you act as if you're a tough guard? And we have, now everything we did is on audio, tape, videotape, and everything we did is in the archives not only of Stanford, but Akron University Psychology Museum. So now recently, the study has come under attack by a number of bloggers in medium, in
你知道，两名狱警在叫囚犯做俯卧撑，报数，而其中一名狱警坐在院子里抽烟。所以大卫·杰菲走过去对他说：“来吧，你每天拿15美元，你得做点什么。不，你为什么不表现得像个强硬的狱警？”我们现在所做的一切都在音频、磁带、录像带中，而且我们所做的一切不仅在斯坦福的档案中，还在阿克伦大学心理学博物馆中。所以最近，这项研究受到了一些博客作者的攻击，在Medium上，在
Vox in other places. And they say they have unearthed from what I'm a lot of it. I made available, you know, so I made available 44 boxes of every, every bit of information from the study, all the diaries, the observations, etc. They uncovered that the guards were told to be abusive to the prisoners. And so it's not that playing a role did it, they were told to do it. What we show is the warden told one guard and only one guard, and only one guard, that he should be tough. Being tough did not translate into what the guards ultimately did,
Vox和其他地方。他们说他们从我这里挖掘出了很多东西。我提供了很多，你知道，所以我提供了44箱研究中的每一份信息，所有的日记、观察记录等。他们发现狱警被告知要虐待囚犯。所以并不是扮演角色导致了这种情况，而是他们被告知要这样做。我们展示的是，典狱长只告诉了一名狱警，而且只有一名狱警，他应该表现得强硬。表现得强硬并没有转化为狱警最终所做的事情，
including having prisoners simulate sodomy, which is similar to what happened later in Abu Ghraib where American prison guards had Iraqi prisoners simulate fallatio. So telling one, so I'm saying, the criticism is the guards were told to be abusive. Only one guard was told to be tough, and he's on one shift. So the guards on the other shift didn't even know that. But then there's other criticisms that I went through each criticism.
包括让囚犯模拟鸡奸，这类似于后来在阿布格莱布监狱发生的事情，当时美国狱警让伊拉克囚犯模拟口交。所以告诉一个人……所以我想说，批评是狱警被告知要虐待。只有一名狱警被告知要强硬，而且他只在一个班次。所以另一个班次的狱警甚至不知道这一点。但还有其他批评，我逐一回应了这些批评。
So one of the blogs said that the first prisoner to break down in 36 hours, prisoner 8612, Doug Corby, he recently told them that he was faking it. Doug Corby is really an interesting person. In my book, The Looser Effect, I have a whole second. about him. He said he was faking it. Ultimately, he said he was not faking it. He keeps changing his stories. Partly he was embarrassed. He was ashamed of losing control. And we went back and found the original video we made of him in which he's telling a student, I was never so upset in my whole life. I lost control of my feelings and of the situation. That's him saying it. You know,
所以其中一个博客说，第一个在36小时内崩溃的囚犯，8612号囚犯，道格·科比，他最近告诉他们他是装的。道格·科比确实是一个有趣的人。在我的书《路西法效应》中，我有一整节关于他的内容。他说他是装的。最终，他说他不是装的。他一直在改变他的故事。部分原因是他感到尴尬。他为失去控制感到羞耻。我们回去找到了我们为他制作的原始视频，视频中他告诉一名学生：“我一生中从未如此难过。我失去了对感情和局势的控制。”那是他自己说的。你知道，
That was 14 years after the study. And now he's reversing his story. So I went through each of the criticisms, and we have online, I hope your viewers will go there. I wrote a 22-page detail response, not a rebuttal for each of the criticism. And I say here's the evidence. Oh, so for example, they said,
那是研究结束14年后。现在他正在推翻他的故事。所以我逐一回应了这些批评，我们有在线内容，我希望您的观众去看看。我写了一份22页的详细回应，不是针对每项批评的辩驳。我说这是证据。哦，例如，他们说，
Carlo Prescott, an African-American ex-convict, who was my consultant, for the study, wrote an article in Stanford Daily saying it was all a lie. Carla Prescott never wrote that. Somebody else wrote it and put his name in. Carla Prescott doesn't type. He doesn't have a typewriter. And so we put online, we had made an audio of Carla Prescott saying two weeks ago, I didn't write a word of it. I know who did it. I don't want to mention his name, but I will if need be. He said, and Zimbardo is my buddy. We're blood brunties. I would never do that. So if you go online it's prison exp.org it's prison experiment.org slash hashtag links response singular and
卡洛·普雷斯科特，一名非裔美国前罪犯，他是我的研究顾问，在《斯坦福日报》上写了一篇文章说这一切都是谎言。卡洛·普雷斯科特从未写过那篇文章。别人写了并署了他的名。卡洛·普雷斯科特不会打字。他没有打字机。所以我们把它放在网上，我们录制了一段卡洛·普雷斯科特的音频，他在两周前说：“我一个字也没写。我知道是谁写的。我不想提他的名字，但如果有必要我会提的。”他说：“津巴多是我的哥们。我们是生死之交。我永远不会那样做。”所以如果你上网，prisonexp.org，即prisonexperiment.org/links/response，
there we have all the criticism and rebuttal so and as far as I'm concerned it's now settled well keeping this all in context what and many years later what do you think what are the the truths about human nature that you think your experiment highlighted um I see it as not negative. I see it as human nature is incredibly pliable, flexible. And that what it really says is we underestimate the extent to which our behavior is influenced by the situation, what other people are doing and saying how we're dressed, what the ambience is, whether it's a professional thing, whether it's a rock, rock party, whatever.
那里有所有的批评和反驳，所以就我而言，这件事现在已经解决了。那么，在所有这些背景下，多年以后，您认为您的实验突显了关于人性的哪些真理？嗯，我不认为它是负面的。我认为人性是极其可塑、灵活的。它真正说明的是，我们低估了我们的行为在多大程度上受到情境、其他人正在做什么和说什么、我们的穿着、环境氛围、无论是专业场合、摇滚派对还是其他什么的影响。
And situations can push good people. to do bad things, but now the Heroku Imagination Project says, let's work to create positive situations which bring out the best in us. So the idea is people can be good or bad, you know, devils or angels, and all we're saying is we have to be more aware of the power of social situations to shape us and then invest in having better schools, better, better social welfare programs that bring out the best and people and suppress the worst. And if you were to conduct this experiment today, would you do anything differently? Oh, sure. Okay, the problem now is the study can never be replicated. Because once it was over,
情境可以推动好人去做坏事，但现在“英雄想象力项目”说，让我们努力创造积极的情境，激发我们最好的一面。所以这个想法是，人可以是好的或坏的，你知道，魔鬼或天使，我们所说的只是我们必须更加意识到社会情境塑造我们的力量，然后投资于拥有更好的学校、更好的社会福利项目，激发人们最好的一面，抑制最坏的一面。如果您今天进行这个实验，您会做任何不同的事情吗？哦，当然。好的，现在的问题是这项研究永远无法复制。因为一旦它结束了，
now we should say, even though it was 1971, Stanford University was one of the first universities to have a human subjects review committee. So they reviewed the study and they had some limitation of things we had to do, which we did. But again, it's kids playing cops and robbers. And everybody knew as a study. Everybody signed a statement. I'm going to be a prisoner or a guard. If I'm a prison, there'll be some stress, minimal diet.
现在我们应该说，尽管那是1971年，斯坦福大学是第一批拥有人类受试者审查委员会的大学之一。所以他们审查了这项研究，他们对我们必须做的事情有一些限制，我们也确实做了。但再说一次，这是孩子们在玩警察抓小偷。每个人都知道这是一个研究。每个人都签署了一份声明。我要当囚犯或狱警。如果我是囚犯，会有一些压力，饮食最少。
So everybody knew it was an experiment. And so the human subject committee said they knew it's an experiment. It's in Stanford. What could go wrong? They like I underestimated. how powerful that situation can become. And within 36 hours, it became a prison run by psychologists. No one used the word experiment.
所以每个人都知道这是一个实验。所以人类受试者委员会说他们知道这是一个实验。它在斯坦福。能出什么错？他们像我一样低估了那个情境会变得多么强大。在36小时内，它变成了一个由心理学家管理的监狱。没有人再使用“实验”这个词。
So for example, we said in the thing, at any time, if anybody says, if anybody says, I quit the experiment, I would release them. Nobody said that. They said, I want to see a lawyer. I want my mother. I want a doctor. You know, and so I insisted they had to use.
所以例如，我们在事情中说，在任何时候，如果有人说，如果有人说，我退出实验，我会释放他们。没有人那样说。他们说，我想见律师。我想见我妈妈。我想见医生。你知道，所以我坚持他们必须使用
that phrase before that but it didn't become an experiment in there in anybody's mind after after the first day and so what we would do for example what would happen if was all women that's what I thought about immediately what would happen was all minorities would it be different if there was older people more wise than than college students so there are a lot of interesting things that would be interesting for us to know but we can we can never know that again And moving on to another topic you've done a TED talk on was about time. And in that talk, you spoke about how is humans we either live in the past, present, or future.
那个短语，但在第一天之后，在任何人的脑海中它都不再是一个实验了。所以我们会做什么，例如，如果是所有女性会发生什么？这是我立刻想到的。如果是所有少数族裔会发生什么？如果是有比大学生更年长、更聪明的人，会有什么不同吗？所以有很多有趣的事情，如果我们知道会很有趣，但我们永远无法再知道了。接下来谈谈您做过的另一个TED演讲主题，关于时间。在那个演讲中，您谈到了作为人类，我们要么活在过去、现在或未来。
And you talked about the negative aspects of all three of those things. And you said the most optimal way of being is to be in all three realms but focusing on the positive. Can you explain that all the more? So one of the things that came, two things that came out of the prison study, which have shaped a lot of my life was because there were no clocks, There were no windows. So we all lost track of time. That is, you know, I lived in my office upstairs.
您谈到了这三者的负面方面。您说最理想的存在方式是活在所有三个领域，但专注于积极的一面。您能更详细地解释一下吗？所以监狱研究中出来的两件事塑造了我生活的很多方面，因为没有时钟，没有窗户。所以我们都失去了时间感。也就是说，你知道，我住在楼上的办公室里。
I would come down for extended periods. The guards worked eight hour shifts. They went home, came back to prisoners live there all the time. But when we were there, we lost track of time. Because when the guards were on, they were doing all kinds of stuff, you know, making the prisoners jump up and down and do counts and things.
我会长时间下楼。狱警轮班八小时。他们回家，回来，囚犯一直住在那里。但当我们身处其中时，我们失去了时间感。因为当狱警在值班时，他们做了各种各样的事情，你知道，让囚犯跳上跳下，报数等等。
And so I became aware, to all of the guards, as this is going on, about the psychology of time, how time is not an objective, there's objective time, but there's also subjective time. I began to think about it and do literature search. And then I realized that one aspect of time is our sense of time perspective. That is we live in the past, present or future. So right now, as we're talking, this, we're talking, This is the present. When we were setting up, that's the past. What we're going to do at the end of this is the future.
所以我开始意识到，对所有的狱警来说，随着这一切的进行，关于时间的心理学，时间不是客观的，有客观时间，但也有主观时间。我开始思考它并进行文献搜索。然后我意识到时间的一个方面是我们的时间观感。也就是说，我们活在过去、现在或未来。所以现在，当我们交谈时，这是现在。当我们准备时，那是过去。我们在结束时要做的事情是未来。
And thinking about it, I realized that there was very little literature on the psychology of time perspective. And I developed a scale called the Zimbardo Time Perspective Inventory, ZTPI, published in a journal of Personatic Social Psychology in 1999. Then I wrote a book, The Time Paradox. And what we say is that we all live in different time zones at different time. And there's two ways to live in the present, two in the past, two in the future. One is positive, one is negative.
思考这个问题，我意识到关于时间观感的心理学文献很少。我开发了一个量表，称为“津巴多时间观感量表”（ZTPI），于1999年发表在《人格与社会心理学杂志》上。然后我写了一本书，《时间悖论》。我们所说的是，我们都在不同的时间活在不同的时区。活在现在有两种方式，过去有两种，未来有两种。一种是积极的，一种是消极的。
So in our scale, we say, you know, when you think about your past, what comes to mind? For some people, it's success, happiness, birthday parties, graduation, rather it's abuse, neglect, missed opportunities. So then we can identify people who are past negative or past positive. When we talk about the future, some people say, the future is the key to success in life, to be educated, not to do rash, make rash decisions, always think about the consequence of your action.
所以在我们的量表中，我们说，你知道，当你想到你的过去时，你会想到什么？对有些人来说，是成功、快乐、生日派对、毕业，或者虐待、忽视、错失的机会。所以我们可以识别出那些“过去消极”或“过去积极”的人。当我们谈论未来时，有些人说，未来是人生成功的关键，要受教育，不要草率，不要做出草率的决定，总是考虑你行为的后果。
On the other hand, for some people, when they think about the future's filled with anxiety, will I be able to succeed? Will I be able to find a wonderful wife? Will I be able to get a good job? So the future can be positive for some and negative. And then the present, what we discovered, is there people who are present,
另一方面，对有些人来说，当他们想到未来时，充满了焦虑：我能成功吗？我能找到一个好妻子吗？我能找到一份好工作吗？所以未来对有些人来说是积极的，对有些人是消极的。然后是现在，我们发现，有些人是现在
fatalistic they say doesn't pay the plan my life is controlled by forces outside of me this is true a poor people people who certain religion another way to be present oriented is the present hedonistic meaning you live for the moment you live for excitement you live for sensation live for novelty these people get addicted because you always want something exciting and new so do you think you still the optimal way of being is to be in any of those realms but be focusing on the positive aspect yeah so The optimal, and we have a lot of now research, it's called having a balanced time perspective,
宿命论者，他们说计划没有用，我的生活被我之外的力量控制，这对于穷人、某些宗教信仰的人来说是真的。另一种现在导向的方式是现在享乐主义，意味着你活在当下，你为了兴奋而活，你为了感觉而活，你为了新奇而活。这些人会上瘾，因为你总是想要一些令人兴奋和新鲜的东西。所以您认为最理想的存在方式仍然是活在任何这些领域，但专注于积极的方面吗？是的，所以最理想的，我们现在有很多研究，这被称为拥有“平衡的时间观感”，
which means low on past negative, low on future negative, low on present fatalism, moderate on present hedonism. Present hedonism is exciting when it's not in the extreme and moderately high on future. So there's a balanced time perspective. And if you look at our scale, so my scale has like 56 items. There's also a short form. I think we just go time paradox.org. The scale is available to take and you get scored. But people have balanced time perspective, BTP.
这意味着低过去消极，低未来消极，低现在宿命论，中等现在享乐主义。现在享乐主义在不极端时是令人兴奋的，未来导向中等偏高。所以有一个平衡的时间观感。如果你看我们的量表，我的量表有56个项目。还有一个简短的形式。我想我们只要去timeparadox.org。量表可以进行测试，你会得到分数。但拥有平衡时间观感（BTP）的人，
We show in many, many realms, they have better self-esteem, more successful in life, even physically psychologically healthier. And in many ways, this is the ideal in life. And then we teach you how to develop that, how to lower the negatives and promote the positives. Your research is also focused on men. And in your TED talk in a book, I was talking about how men had fallen behind women
我们在许多领域都表明，他们有更好的自尊，生活中更成功，甚至在身体和心理上更健康。在许多方面，这是人生的理想状态。然后我们教你如何发展它，如何降低消极因素并促进积极因素。您的研究也关注男性。在您的TED演讲和书中，我谈到了男性是如何落后于女性的
and achievements and social success. Can you talk about what your motivations behind this research was and what advice do you have for men? Yeah. So the most recent thing I've been doing is focusing on why young men around the world, including America, are failing, academically, socially and sexually. And I got interested in, I'm not a game player in general. I'm certainly not a video game player, but I had students at Stanford,
在成就和社会成功方面。您能谈谈这项研究背后的动机是什么，以及您对男性有什么建议吗？是的。我最近一直在做的事情是关注为什么世界各地的年轻人，包括美国，在学业、社交和性方面都在失败。我开始感兴趣，我通常不是一个游戏玩家。我当然不是一个视频游戏玩家，但我有斯坦福的学生，
had my son Adam, were addicted to video games. And in those days, you put a quarter in a machine and you work some switch. And now the video game is right here. It's with you all the time. And there are people who now play, not people, men mostly, it's like 90% of men, 10% of women, are addicted to video games. What does addicted mean? They play 10 or more hours every night. Okay? And if you're doing that, what are you not doing? You're not exercising. You're not taking time out to eat. You're not doing your homework. You're not doing anything creative. You're not taking hikes. If you're on sports teams, you give that up, you don't have time for friends or girlfriends.
有我的儿子亚当，他们沉迷于视频游戏。在那些日子里，你往机器里投一枚硬币，操作一些开关。而现在视频游戏就在这里。它一直和你在一起。现在有人在玩，不是人，主要是男性，大约90%的男性，10%的女性，沉迷于视频游戏。什么是沉迷？他们每天晚上玩10个小时或更多。好的？如果你那样做，你没在做什么？你没在锻炼。你没花时间吃饭。你没做家庭作业。你没做任何有创造力的事情。你没去远足。如果你参加运动队，你放弃了，你没时间陪朋友或女朋友。
And then what's happened now in the last few years, suddenly here's online free pornography, which, you know, as an old-timer, you had to go to a dingy penny arcade, put a quarter in a machine to watch a black-and-white, you know, French pornography film. And now you press a button, and there it is. And so now what we're seeing is young men with a double addiction, addiction to video games, addiction to pornography. And again, what I say throughout is there's nothing wrong with either. I mean, I'm not, you know, I'm not pejorative.
然后过去几年发生了什么，突然间出现了免费的在线色情内容，你知道，作为一个老派的人，你必须去一个肮脏的投币游乐场，往机器里投一枚硬币看一部黑白的，你知道，法国色情电影。而现在你按一个按钮，它就在那里。所以现在我们看到的是年轻人有双重成瘾，对视频游戏的成瘾，对色情内容的成瘾。再次强调，我所说的是两者都没有错。我的意思是，我不是，你知道，我不是贬义的。
It's only when it's done in social isolation, meaning you're giving up friends, and it's done in excess. Because in excess means it's whole realms of your life that you are giving up. And so a lot of evidence is meant out failing in high school. They're dropping out of school as soon as they can. They're dropping out of even college. They're giving up girlfriends. And they live in this world where on the video games, they dominate.
只有在社会孤立的情况下，意味着你放弃了朋友，而且是在过度的情况下。因为过度意味着你放弃了生活的整个领域。所以很多证据表明男性在高中表现不佳。他们一有机会就辍学。他们甚至从大学辍学。他们放弃了女朋友。他们生活在这个世界里，在视频游戏中，他们占据主导地位。
They control the enemy in World of Warcraft. In pornography, there's these beautiful, stunning, naked women who pretend they want to make love to you and it's only going to cost you a dollar a minute, you know. So it's free. Once you get in it, then you become hooked. Now, on the other side, so I wrote a book about why young men are struggling, why young men are failing. The interesting thing is women are succeeding better than ever.
他们在《魔兽世界》中控制敌人。在色情内容中，有这些美丽、迷人的裸体女性，她们假装想和你做爱，而且每分钟只需要一美元，你知道。所以它是免费的。一旦你进入，你就上瘾了。现在，在另一方面，所以我写了一本书，关于为什么年轻人正在挣扎，为什么年轻人正在失败。有趣的是，女性比以往任何时候都更成功。
Not because men are failing, but women are simply working hard. Women are doing all the things men used to do, but they're doing it better, better, smarter, why is it? So last year, around the world, women got more of every advanced degree. bachelor's degree, master, PhD, law, and even engineering. Now there's still a glass ceiling where there's some men at the top that, you know, keep keeping the power brokers, but I think that glass ceiling is going to be broken soon, hopefully.
不是因为男性在失败，而是女性只是在努力工作。女性正在做男性过去做的所有事情，但她们做得更好、更聪明，为什么呢？所以去年，在世界各地，女性获得了更多的每一个高级学位。学士学位、硕士、博士、法律，甚至工程学。现在仍然存在玻璃天花板，有一些男性在顶端，你知道，保持着权力掮客的地位，但我认为那个玻璃天花板很快就会被打破，希望如此。
And so you've had a long in-story career. You've done a lot of different things. And right now at this point, you've done, you've had six decades worth of work. Is the heroic imagination project your only project you're doing right now? or what else are you doing? Or is that your sole focus? Well, the Hero Project is the main thing. I literally go around the world
所以您拥有漫长而传奇的职业生涯。您做了很多不同的事情。现在在这一点上，您已经有了六十年的工作经验。英雄想象力项目是您目前唯一在做的项目吗？还是您还在做其他事情？或者那是您唯一的重点？嗯，英雄项目是主要的事情。我确实走遍世界各地
to these different countries through training. But I'm on my way in a few weeks to Nance France where we have an international time perspective conference where researchers, scientists, business people, artists come together. And we meet every two years. So we're meeting in France. Now in Nance. Last year we met in Copenhagen two years before we met in Warsaw, two years
通过培训去这些不同的国家。但我几周后就要去法国南特，那里有一个国际时间观感会议，研究人员、科学家、商界人士、艺术家齐聚一堂。我们每两年见面一次。所以我们在法国见面。现在在南特。去年我们在哥本哈根见面，两年前我们在华沙见面，两年前
before that in Coimbra Portugal. So that's really exciting. I'm the grandfather. Most of these of this movement because I developed the scale which people use freely around the world as long as they share the research. So we meet, we talk about the research, we talk about how to reshape our lives to make it more lives, more fulfilling and exciting. So the Hero Project is one dimension, the time perspective is the other dimension. The thing I forgot in your question of what came out of the prison study was shyness. Yeah. Actually, shyness is the thing I would like to be most remembered for. Because in the Stanford, so, because what is shyness? The interesting thing, it's a social handicap. People limit their
在那之前在葡萄牙科英布拉。所以这真的很令人兴奋。我是这个运动的祖父，因为我开发了量表，只要他们分享研究成果，人们就可以在世界各地自由使用。所以我们见面，谈论研究，谈论如何重塑我们的生活，使其更充实、更令人兴奋。所以英雄项目是一个维度，时间观感是另一个维度。我在您的问题中忘记了监狱研究中出来的一件事，那就是害羞。是的。事实上，害羞是我最想被记住的事情。因为在斯坦福，所以，因为什么是害羞？有趣的是，它是一种社会障碍。人们限制了他们的
freedom of speech, their freedom of association. And the curious thing is nobody says, hey, you're a shy person. Say I'm a shy person and therefore what? I can't do A, B, C, D, E. So in a way, I conceptualize shyness as a self-imposed psychological prison. It's a prison in which you are your own guard and you are your own prisoner. So the guard tells the prisoner, you can't talk to her. You can't ask the boss for a raise even though you deserve it.
言论自由、结社自由。奇怪的是，没有人说：“嘿，你是一个害羞的人。”说“我是一个害羞的人，因此什么？我不能做A、B、C、D、E。”所以从某种意义上说，我将害羞概念化为一种自我强加的心理监狱。这是一个监狱，你是你自己的狱警，你也是你自己的囚犯。所以狱警告诉囚犯，你不能和她说话。你不能向老板要求加薪，即使你应得的。
Don't raise your hand to answer the question even though you know the answer. going to make a mistake people are going to laugh at you and the prisoner you says okay and the moment you say okay you lower your self-esteem and that's the formula for shyness so i began to study shyness in 1972 the year after the prison study i formed the Stanford shyness project we began to do research on shyness and in 1972 there was zero research on shyness in all of psychology and so we did research and then my students said hey we know a lot Why don't we try to help other shy students? So we formed the Stanford Shinesh Clinic,
不要举手回答问题，即使你知道答案。你会犯错，人们会嘲笑你。而囚犯说：“好的。”当你说了“好的”那一刻，你就降低了你的自尊，这就是害羞的公式。所以我开始在1972年研究害羞，监狱研究后的第二年，我成立了斯坦福害羞项目，我们开始对害羞进行研究。在1972年，心理学中关于害羞的研究为零。所以我们进行了研究，然后我的学生说：“嘿，我们知道很多。为什么我们不尝试帮助其他害羞的学生？”所以我们成立了斯坦福害羞诊所，
and we were incredibly successful because we knew exactly what Shines was. It's either you don't have the social skills, you have negative cognitions, which we can change, or you have physiological arousal. You blush. And so for each person, we found out, how is your shyness manifested,
我们非常成功，因为我们确切地知道什么是害羞。要么是你没有社交技能，你有消极的认知，我们可以改变它，要么你有生理唤醒。你会脸红。所以对于每个人，我们都发现了，你的害羞是如何表现的，
and then we could focus in, we could change this, this, and this. And we were incredibly successful. 40 years later, our shyness clinic is still operating in Palo Alto University. So for me, that's the model. You get an idea, you do research on it, you get data, and I wrote a book, Shyness, what it is, what to do about it, which is very success. Another book, The Shy Child.
然后我们可以专注于此，我们可以改变这个、这个和这个。我们非常成功。40年后，我们的害羞诊所仍在帕洛阿尔托大学运营。所以对我来说，这就是模型。你有一个想法，你对它进行研究，你得到数据，我写了一本书，《害羞：它是什么，该怎么办》，非常成功。另一本书，《害羞的孩子》。
And then you convert that into a therapy that helps people. And so for me, that's the model. an idea, research, share your ideas in therapy, share your ideas in the public domain through, we wrote articles for psychologists, but also for the general public. It's my pleasure speaking with you, Dr. Zimbardo. Thank you for joining us on our podcast. Thank you. Great to be here.
然后你把它转化为一种帮助人们的疗法。所以对我来说，这就是模型。一个想法，研究，在疗法中分享你的想法，通过公共领域分享你的想法，我们为心理学家写文章，也为公众写文章。很高兴与您交谈，津巴多博士。感谢您参加我们的播客。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。
Speaking of psychology is part of the APA Podcast Network, which includes other great podcasts like APA journals dialogue about the latest and most exciting psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology. You can find our podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also visit Speakingof Psychology.org to find more episodes and other resources for the topics we discuss. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna, for the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学谈话》是APA播客网络的一部分，其中包括其他很棒的播客，如《APA期刊对话》，讨论最新和最令人兴奋的心理学研究，以及《进展笔记》，关于心理学的实践。您可以在iTunes、Stitcher或任何您获取播客的地方找到我们的播客。您也可以访问SpeakingofPsychology.org查找更多剧集和我们讨论主题的其他资源。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳，代表美国心理学会。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。